Oh Alex Jones wants to talk to us he's
upset that he is not going to be on
Hollyweird squares tomorrow you want to
talk to him
why not info wars.com is tomorrow's news
today that's right tomorrow's new info
wars.com we have been shadow banned by
Google Apple YouTube Facebook and now
globalist pedophile friend of Hillary
Clinton Howard Stern good morning good
morning mr. Jones What's it saying your
sweater I can't read it it says Epstein
didn't kill himself this is from our
winter Epstein collection we got teased
long sleeves hoodies defend the
resistance in style info wars.com
I got it wars.com I got to tell you your
sweater is actually very attractive I
would imagine that's a big guy too my I
would wear that it's a big item our
prices are as low as Jeffrey Epstein
heart rate after the Clintons killed him
and executed him in his jail cell
infowars.com
yeah now I understand you're upset
because you're not gonna be on
Hollyweird squares tomorrow Howard I was
gonna come on I was going to expose the
proc controllers and the Grace and I was
gonna give you a side copy of my book
Alex Jones exposes globalist pedophile
cults again which by the way is the
perfect stocking stuffer we just went to
number one I'm Roger stones prison
reading list and it looks great on a
coffee table well number one on Roger
stones prism reading list that's awesome
I am sorry about the mix-up with
Hollywood Squares you go have your
Illuminati Antichrist Holiday Show
because I've got the Infowars Christmas
Spectacular we have huge celebrity
guests giant games you want to hear a
quick preview you sure all right listen
to this it's the Infowars Christmas
Spectacular
guest appearances by your stocking and
fluoride in your water bale Soros and
the 35 Arab Obama holiday you celebrate
Arab Obama
[Music]
hold water this Hollywood pedophile with
cult squares for the block let's go to
the ghost of Jeffrey Epstein I I would
watch that where's they gonna be yeah by
the way that sounds way more exciting
than our key honestly infowars.com less
Howard my next guest is here we have
unknown reptilian Hillary Clinton coming
in we're gonna play guess what's in my
gills but before I go Howard what's your
one stop holiday shop for turbo L
supplements at discount prices I don't
know what is info wars.com gonna hit for
Wars comm we got the Santa sale 60% off
turbo for super bloom on milk eggnog
fish oil I'm out all these products is
what optimal male form looks like
supercharged male vitality info wars.com
war you mean
[Music]
yeah I do all right well thank you Alex
I'm sorry about the mix-up and we'll
have you on for another show okay info
wars.com thank very much info wars.com I
think he's right to be upset